a little while ago i was given a
japanese periodic table it's really
quite fun with lots of pictures on it
but i was always a bit mystified why on
element 75 rhenium there was a picture
of a japanese scientist and if you look
carefully it says 1908 and then last
week i was sent a scientific paper by
our youtube fan naga yasun nawa who
lives in japan the one who gave me this
terrific
coat this happy which explained the
whole thing
so now i'm going to tell you
if you look at my sleeve here element 43
that's now called technesium and element
75 rhenium one of the triumphs of
periodic table as produced by mendeleev
is that it predicted where elements
should be found in the beginning of the
20th century the periodic table looked
much like the one that's here this one
is slightly later it's from about 1920
and the important thing is that there is
a hole here where element 43 should be
and there is another hole here where
element 75 should be
our story involves a japanese chemist
called tagawa who was born a few years
before mendeleev even proposed the
periodic table and in 1906 he got a
scholarship to work at university
college london with the famous chemists
of william ramsey who was one of the
first winners of the nobel prize in
chemistry who discovered the element
argonne william ramsey was very keen to
get a supply of helium gas and at the
beginning of the 20th century you
couldn't just buy helium in a cylinder
so instead he bought a quarter of a ton
of a rather strange mineral called
thorionite from sri lanka thorianite
contains the element thorium you may
have seen my sample of thorium already
thorium decays to make alpha particles
which generates helium that is trapped
in this mineral so if you grind it up
carefully in the right way you can trap
the helium gas when agawa arrived at
university college london
there was a lot of this mineral
and he was given
i think about one and a half kilos of
this mineral and asked to
analyze it to see if he could find
anything interesting he did
lots of chemical separations you can see
in the paper i was given there's this
huge diagram of how he separated
different fractions and he ended up with
a small amount of material
which could be a salt of a new element
in those days the only way you could
identify an element was by measuring its
atomic weight which involved
knowing the formula of the
salt that you had got
and then calculating what the weight of
the metal was agawa got the formula of
the salt wrong so he thought he had made
enderment 43 he called it nipponium in
honor of japan sir william ramsey
encouraged him to call it nipponium with
the symbol np
which is now used for neptunium but it
turned out he had prepared element 75
but he never realized this after three
years he went back to japan
and bought some of his own thorium night
to continue his studies and spent a lot
of time analyzing this and trying to
produce more samples what he didn't know
was that element 43 is radioactive you
can see our video about technetium and
its radioactivity
in 1925 rhenium was isolated by a
husband and wife team called nodak in
germany and they also thought they'd
made element 43 but they were wrong
about that so
in most periodic tables it has been
assigned that the nodaks were the
discoveries of rhenium and they were in
the sense
that it is their work that led to the
study of rhenium but people have gone on
studying agawas results and particularly
the x-ray spectrum
of the elements which can be interpreted
as being the x-ray spectrum of rhenium
when they were recording the spectrum
they didn't know what the spectrum of
rhenium should look like so it wasn't
that they were trying to fiddle their
results to fit the expected pattern but
very surprisingly they've been huge
arguments did agawa discover irinium or
not
and reading this article
to me at least it looks quite convincing
but i think there's quite an important
message first of all there is the
message that chemists who were working
120 years ago really had to do very
difficult experiments under conditions
which modern chemists would not be able
to do now we're not probably skilled
enough
to get a few milligrams out of a
kilogram and a half of rock but also if
you're going to try and discover an
element
even if you actually isolate it
if you identify it wrongly you may not
get the credit that's due to you that
brings us back
to my japanese periodic table i think it
is really good that with this periodic
table agawa got his proper recognition
at least in one periodic table here
i've got a modern japanese periodic
table without the pictures and of course
you can see down here element
113 nihonium which was synthesized in
japan it was named in 2017
nihonium
has its name derived from japan
just in the same way that nipponium had
its name derived from japan so it is
possible that if agawa had been
recognized in time that he discovered
rhenium we could have two elements named
after japan on the periodic table
[Music]
[Applause]
you